what do you want to do with your one wow
and precious life tell me something you
never told before before i walk through
the door i
adore you i adore you i do zack is a
fighter
but his body is shutting down
[Music]
i would marry you today if i could hold
my hand i'll
squeeze it back
[Music]
you get to decide
[Music]
clouds rated pg-13 streaming october
16th on disney plus
here's the thing i like you i know your
diagnosis complicates things but
i don't care i mean do you like me yes i
do even though
i don't have cancer make your move
romeo
most teenagers feel like they're
invincible not the superman kind of
midschool the kind of invincible that
tricks you into thinking tomorrow might
be a better day to start chasing your
dreams
we've been through this just breeze you
are my best friend so you are morally
obligated to say
nice things to me everybody else out
there is not my best friend if everyone
else doesn't like it
then they're idiots and while there's a
lot that i don't know at my age
what i do know is this we all have
limited time
tell me something you never told before
before i walk through the door
i adore you i adore you hi how are you
i'm off chemo is it because it worked or
do what you're facing
is scary but you get to decide what
matters
most now never give up
a front door are you writing a song
hello i was thinking might be cool if we
did something that was just ours
[Music]
zach have you looked on youtube you have
20 000 views
you should be happy i thought this is
what you wanted it doesn't really matter
what i want because it's not going to
happen
it's not fair please stop i have nothing
to give you no rings
no future nothing there's so much in
there that the world needs to hear
what are you gonna do with it
[Music]
it's my favorite song
[Music]
in the end i just want to make people
happy i zachary zobiak i'm asking you
yes please for as long as i can
because what some people take for
granted
others are fighting for and believe me
i'm a fighter
you